tori
what a game you were a ball of fun to
watch
how are you feeling right now
yeah i'm actually i'm like very happy it
was a dream come true like of course we
all want to win but i knew that was a
very slim chance so like i had fun it
was a great experience i know it was a
hard tribal last night um but i have a
lot of peace about it so i'm i'm excited
to be here talk about my game
yeah well i want to get into the nitty
gritty in terms of all of it with you
but first i want to ask you about your
dominant
individual immunity performance do you
think
that you were going to pull off that
back-to-back immunity win during this
critical stage in the game
here's the thing so i came in like in
pre-season interviews saying that like i
wanted to be the woman to break the
record and win five individual immunity
challenges and like i don't just say
that because i have like a false sense
of self or whatever like i believe i
can't because i have these weird skills
that translate really well to the like
individual immunity challenges and
survivor they don't necessarily work
well in like organized sports or things
like that but i knew that i could so i
also knew if my back was up against the
wall and i had to literally save my life
in the game by winning i believe that i
could pull it out i couldn't do it a
third time but we're not going to talk
about that
you know what two out of three is a good
record you should be proud of yourself
and
this week when jeff split everybody into
the two tribes one was comprised of the
four women and jonathan so when you saw
you were in this group were you worried
or did you feel like there was a lot of
opportunity for you to move yourself
forward
i actually thought it was a great setup
for me because i had been working on my
relationships with marianne i had a good
relationship with lindsay i was working
on my relationship with jonathan i
didn't realize till watching back how
much he didn't trust me though um and
then there was a really large target of
drea because we knew a lot of her
advantages and i was trying to tell
people about the paint on her arm and
like there's something else going on
here we don't know about and so i saw it
as like kind of one of my best case
scenarios of being able to squeak by one
more time by being with people that i
had built built social bonds with as
well of like a pretty big target that we
could get out
so when you go into this challenge
unfortunately it's the one you don't win
did you think your time was up but or
were you hopeful it sounds like you were
hopeful yeah i mean i'm always going to
be hopeful because i also i love
survivor i know survivor even when it
looks like there's zero hope like
crazier things have happened and so
it sucked i mean and i look back and
it's like
it's almost better knowing that i wasn't
even gonna come in second to winning
that challenge like i was just gonna
have to rely on hopefully
strategizing and you know it didn't work
out but can't win them all i had to give
jonathan a chance you know
i'm kidding
yeah exactly yeah you got to spread the
love that was your gift to jonathan and
everybody
so when you walked into that tribal
council or rather before you went to
tribal council what was the intended
plan and did you feel confident that
the group
was going to be able to pull it off
yeah i going into tribal of course i am
terrified because paranoia and i was
a target at every single tribal i had
been to but i did have a lot of
confidence and i fully was believing
that we were going to go into tribal
drea was going to get blindsided i would
probably have a vote thrown my way from
her
and
i was going to get by and hopefully gain
footing in the game and i really do
believe that if some circumstances were
slightly shifted for example if romeo
got voted out instead of rocks or if we
had gone to tribal first i really do
think that drea would have been the
target and i would still be in the game
and when everybody walked into the
tribal council there was shock across
everyone's face seeing that roxborough
was sitting there so who did you
originally think was going to be sitting
there and then what were you thinking
when you saw that it was roxroy well
none of us really gave much thought to
the other tribal council of like oh
what's gonna happen how's that gonna
impact our vote because we were all like
a hundred percent sure it was romeo like
even people watching i'm like it looks
like it's romeo that's how we felt in
the game too so it was just more so
shocking of like
what happened to where it was brought
like it didn't necessarily make sense to
us
at the time and that's where you know
things started to
go south for me
yeah i feel like when jeff splits the
tribe into two tribes and he talks about
information being really important and
seeing that juror i think that this is
an example of how seeing who the new
juror is really affects the game
yeah and i think that there was a lot
that affected the game last night and i
think that you were able to really be
present and be part of what i think will
be one of the most memorable tribal
councils in a while i think that
the
issues that were talked about and the
points of view that were talked about
were so illuminating so what did you get
out of being able to experience that
firsthand yeah
i kind of assumed coming into the season
due to the new diversity initiatives
that a topic surrounding race would come
up i just honestly had no idea i would
be part of that conversation
because i didn't feel like i had
anything to offer to that conversation
but what i actually have learned looking
back is
one of the most important things i can
do is allow that conversation to be had
and give space and not try to invalidate
because i don't fully understand and so
even while i was sitting in that tribal
and i knew when jerry was going to play
her idol i was going home like that was
it
and i still was able to have so much
peace because for me me going home is
just my survivor dream coming to an end
which is really hard for me to like wrap
my head around because i'm a super fan i
wanted this for six years but i knew
even in that moment if drea or marianne
were to go home that would be a lot more
meaningful deeper and hurtful for them
so i actually had peace i was just
owning and i was going to kind of step
out of the way you know i was kind of
creating chaos and being messy all
season but i didn't i didn't want to do
that i felt like it would be
inappropriate and disrespectful for the
moment that was happening and so i think
hopefully something people can take away
is even if you don't understand or
you're not actively part of that
conversation it can be really powerful
to just sit back allow that to happen
and to listen
mm-hmm
and so i what what i thought was
interesting is you noted that it was
really hard to switch back into game
mode after that conversation and i think
a lot of viewers don't realize that the
players actually have a lot of power in
tribal council in terms of dictating
when they're ready to vote so can you
share more about the decision to not go
into the private voting area as usual
and do you think that there's more that
you could have done to plead your case
um
yes well for example like i did ask jeff
if we could just not have a tribal
because he was making it very clear like
this is your tribal decide and so i
asked like can we just not vote then
like it just
i'm not saying like never vote but maybe
give us more time or vote in the morning
or just let me slide by but it did just
feel like
it needed more especially like i'm a
therapist and no one knew i was a
therapist in that situation but i saw
people being very vulnerable and
sensitive and it for me especially it
just felt so wrong to oh let's go
straight back into the game also knowing
because me going straight back into the
game man i was gonna fight for my life i
was gonna try to do something i didn't
have many options so i was still gonna
try but for me i was just once jeff said
we did have to vote and we didn't have
to go through the formalities i was like
okay then i'm gonna go play my shot in
the dark i didn't even ask i just said
i'm going to go play my shot in the dark
because that's all i had and that felt
appropriate and respectful for the
situation
and i don't think that anyone could deny
that you were a fighter in the game you
were scrappy you were doing whatever you
needed to do to try to at least get
ahead and i feel like that's what you
have to do on survivor and i feel like
as a viewer it looks like when you got
to the merge
it looked like you were on the outs you
were at the bottom what did you think
that your way forward would be at the
merge if you weren't winning the
immunities um
so my plan going into the merge was to
have this persona of like ika is totally
fractured tori and roxroy can't get
along at all tori is a free agent while
in the back of my mind i was still going
to maintain and stay eca strong because
i knew that was best for my game i kind
of wanted to like have my cake and eat
it too um but so i also wanted to cause
more division on the surface between
like me and roxroy so that people would
tell rox information they would tell me
information and we could feed that to
each other and rox was feeding me
information in the game that was helpful
and so
going into the merge that was kind of my
plan to have both avenues um but then it
just ended up ika didn't want to work
with me primarily because drea didn't
want to stay eca strong and then my
other option of being this free agent to
work with people
no one wanted to give me the time of day
no one trusted me because there were
rumors going on that i was searching
through people's bags and i was dumping
out my water to go search for immunity
idols none of which were true but
at that point like the only thing i
could rely on was uh immunities
it's so weird how rumors like that can
really take take a life of their own in
survivor and this is where the
perception and everything is so
important so when you look back is there
anything in your game that you think you
could have done differently
oh yes yes yes yes like since i didn't
win clearly there are things i should
have done differently um i think for me
it goes all the way back to that very
first challenge for the flint when the
amulet was part of that challenge and it
was between me or drea we were both
gonna run
and she wanted to do the shorter
distance and i wanted to do the shorter
distance because i just wanted to and so
i lied to her and i told her oh the
second leg is shorter
like and that's karma for me because
like if i would have gotten that amulet
and i would have connected with hai and
lindsey i think it would have been a
totally different game um but then i
think another thing early on in the game
that would have set me up better was
reassuring my alliance members of zack
and swafi of like hey i'm lying to other
people when i talk to them like you guys
are my alliance that really hurt my game
so there's so many things i would i
would do differently i feel like i
played 10 of my potential in survivor
because i just i never had people to
play with or work with
i think that that self-reflection is so
important and now as you look back
because i know you're a huge survivor
fan what did the experience teach you
about yourself overall
i'd say one of the biggest things and
this is a big part of my journey on the
island too and so
it never got shown but you know i'm a
therapist for women with eating
disorders and i've had my own struggles
and so i came into survivor
very much wanting to gain a deeper
appreciation for like what what can my
body do what is what is it capable of
because like back home really all that
matters to a young woman is like how
does it look in the mirror but on
survivor you don't get hair makeup stuff
you don't even have mirrors so i wanted
to appreciate my body for what it was
capable of and like that's why in my
little exit thing i was like i can do so
much more than i thought and so i really
have gained a lot deeper appreciation
for my body and what it can do like
that's a message that i want other
people to be able to do in their own
life of like let's think of our bodies
outside of just the way it looks in a
mirror
i think that there's so much to win
besides the actual win and i think that
with you you were determined you were
scrappy and you were fun to watch so
honestly thank you for going out there
and playing as you and thank you for
chatting today and honestly tori i wish
you all of the best thank you so nice to
meet you
you